here's our challenge name your top three  topics in technology today we asked  around and got blockchain ai and  kubernetes how about you do you agree or  did we miss a big one let us know please  post a comment below with your  suggestions and we'll make sure to add  them to our plans for future videos  as a small thank you for your  contribution if we publish a video based  on a suggestion we'll give a shout out  to the first person who posted it thanks  again for watching your feedback is  important to us if you're not seeing  what you're looking for please let us  know and if you haven't already please  subscribe to our channel